[Musique]
préparez un délicieux repas ne
s'improvise pas
vivre non plus
et vivre heureux encore moins
s'il existe un tas de recettes pour
cuisiner celle pour celle pour vivre
sont plutôt rares
alors aujourd'hui
j'aimerais vous parler d'une d'une
méthode
oh rassurez-vous je n'ai pas la
prétention de vous apprendre à être
heureux mais si je peux vous aider un
peu pourquoi pas
il m'aura fallu 30 ans pour découvrir
que le bonheur est accessible du coup je
peux peut-être je peux peut-être vous
faire gagner un peu de temps
il y a des personnes de moins de 30 ans
dans la salle
oui là je rassurez-vous si vous avez
plus de 30 ans c'est bon aussi il n'est
jamais trop tard pour être heureux
et donc
durant mes 30 premières années
et bien je vous les êtres une fée et
avec ma baguette magique faire
disparaître tous les méchants pour faire
jaillir le bonheur
mais ça ne marchait pas
jusqu'au jour où j'ai découvert que le
la baguette magique
c'était moi
alors
j'écris mon histoire et puis j'ai fondé
une association pour accompagner les
victimes et toutes ces personnes qui ne
croient plus au bonheur et puis je suis
allée à la rencontre de jeunes pour
partager avec ces étapes justement de
cette méthode
et
chaque fois je recevais
des échos que ça marchait
et donc qui dit baguette magique dit
aussi formule magique
oxy d'olive à vous aussi de lire
et oui c'est le nom de cette méthode des
gens heureux
oxy nous allons d'abord faire
connaissance avec la personne unique et
formidable que vous êtes si si
fort de ses premières étapes il y en a
quatre nous pourrons ensuite nous ouvrir
aux autres et nous diriger gentiment
vers le pays des gens heureux
allons-y
première étape o pour objectif
ayez toujours un objectif un but un rêve
on ne peut pas avancer sans objectif
mais attention 3 règles la première
cet objectif doit être clair et précis
en deuxième lieu il faudra que cet
objectif soit fixé par vous et vous seul
c'est terminé de laisser les autres
contrôler votre vie c'est vous le patron
enfin troisième et dernière règle est
probablement la plus importante
ne laissez personne vous dire que vous
ne pouvez pas réaliser votre objectif
réaliser votre rêve
parce que croyez-moi ils seront nombreux
lorsque j'ai décidé d'écrire mon
histoire j'ai rencontré un tas de gens
qui m'ont dit oh c'est une bonne idée
mais j'ai aussi rencontré des gens qui
m'ont dit mais les biographies c'est
pour les gens célèbres toi tu n'es pas
connu personne ne va lire ta biographie
c'est pas une bonne idée
[Musique]
je n'ai pas écouté et je suis allé au
bout de mon objectif
et cette année je suis fier de publier
mon sixième livre qui ont toujours
autant de succès
ne laissez personne brisé ou vous
détourner de vos objectifs
deuxième étape c'est pour capacité et
oui elles sont utiles les capacités pour
atteindre ses objectifs l'un ne va pas
sans l'autre mais encore faut-il savoir
de quoi on est capable et bien justement
vous fixez des objectifs va vous
permettre de découvrir vos capacités
mais aussi de quoi vous n'êtes pas
capable ou ce que vous devez apprendre
mais là aussi il y a une règle à
respecter
il va falloir oser il va falloir se
lancer
et surtout il va falloir se délier de
ses croyances qui vous paralyse
enfin un troisième étape c'est pour
confiance
si capacité à cette petite touche de
rationnel on peut mesurer la capacité on
ne peut pas mesurer la confiance c'est
cette part d'irrationnelle qu'il y a en
chacun de nous c'est cette petite voix
vous savez qui vous dit des choses vas-y
n'y va pas fais attention mais
aujourd'hui on ne l'écoute plus cette
petite voix cette petite voix noyée dans
le bruit le Brouard Internet et tout ça
il faut de temps en temps s'arrêter et
écouter cette petite voix qui est un
excellent guide pourquoi parce que c'est
le GPS du cœur
lorsque j'ai arrêté mes études je
n'avais plus la force de continuer je me
suis fait la promesse un objectif
de reprendre mes études plus tard je ne
savais pas quand ni comment mais c'était
un objectif mon père était au courant de
cet objectif et régulièrement il
remettait le disque alors ma fille tes
études ça y est tu vas les reprendre oui
oui papa un jour
à l'approche de la quarantaine
j'étais en vacances au Maroc et mon papa
remet le disque alors ma fille tes
études et là je le regarde et je lui dis
mais enfin papa mais j'en suis incapable
me voilà aujourd'hui maman de 3 enfants
je travaille à temps plein j'ai une
maison à gérer quand veux-tu que je
reprenne des études il m'a regardé il
m'a dit mais pourquoi tu dis que tu n'es
pas capable essaye d'abord et puis si tu
travailles la journée tu peux étudier le
soir il doit bien exister des cours du
soir en Belgique je me suis dit mon père
est fou mais ma petite voix me disait et
si tu essayais
et j'ai essayé et non seulement j'ai
obtenu à gradur en informatique et forte
de cette réussite j'ai poursuivi avec
une licence en fiscalité plus tard j'ai
obtenu une certification en live
coaching un brevet de secouriste et
dernièrement pour les besoins de mon
métier je viens d'être certifié prince 2
project management et agile project
management
on est capable de bien plus de choses
qu'on ne le croit
et écouter toujours votre petite voix
enfin quatrième étape i pour image ah
cette image comme on l'habille mon film
au fil des années cette image il y a
d'abord cette société qui nous formate
mais oui à l'école on nous force à
prendre tous de la même manière alors
que nous sommes tous uniques et
différents et puis il y a l'entourage la
famille les amis qui nous forcent à être
la personne qu'on n'est pas et
finalement le miroir nous renvoie une
image qui n'est pas la nôtre mais celle
que les autres veulent voir
alors il y a aussi le passé qui peut
parfois avoir abîmé l'image si on a été
victime de violence de maltraitance
d'humiliation on a parfois honte
et du coup cette image
elle est abîmée et c'est difficile de se
fixer des objectifs quand on a une image
abîmée alors j'ai une excellente
nouvelle pour vous
nous ne sommes pas la somme de nos actes
il y a moi cette personne cette baguette
magique qui a une identité unique et une
carte ADN unique et puis il y a les
actes commis ou subies
en ce qui concerne les actes commis il y
a les succès qui embellissent l'image et
puis il y a les échecs on a tous droit à
l'erreur
parmi les actes subis il y a les belles
choses comme la tendresse l'amour le
respect qui vont favoriser l'image mais
il y a aussi toutes ces toutes ces
choses qui vont vous abîmer comme les
humiliations la moquerie la violence la
maltraitance
et bien
dites-vous une fois pour toutes que vous
n'êtes pas responsable de la bêtise de
la méchanceté de la cruauté des autres
il faut que la honte change de camp
j'étais jusqu'à mes 30 ans victime de
violence de maltraitance de moquerie
d'humiliation
et quand à l'approche de la trentaine
j'étais maman d'un petit garçon et
victime de violences conjugales j'ai eu
un déclic j'ai compris une fois pour
toutes que le problème n'était pas chez
moi mais chez celui qui me battait chez
celui qui m'humiliait la honte doit
définitivement changer de camp ne
laissez personne abîmer votre image
voilà vous êtes prêts
oxy vous a permis de découvrir la
personne unique et formidable que vous
êtes nous allons maintenant nous diriger
vers le pays des gens heureux avec cette
sixième étape do pour donner
il n'y a pas de plus belle action pour
s'enrichir que celle de donner
mais attention
il y a deux règles
la première règle c'est donner sans
espoir de retour et la deuxième règle
c'est donner oui mais ne pas oublier
autrement dit on va d'abord se donner à
soi et puis on donnera aux autres c'est
comme dans l'avion on met d'abord le
masque à soi-même avant de mettre le
masque éventuellement aux enfants
ne jamais s'oublier et ne rien attendre
en retour tout ce que vous donnerez sera
multipliée toutes les personnes que j'ai
rencontrées et qui étaient investie de
manière bénévole dans des associations
avait cette chose en commun et elles
étaient épanouies donner répond à un
besoin relationnel qui est celui de
donner un sens à sa vie
cette sixième étape nous arrivons tout
doucement à lit lit pour libérer
et oui une fois que vous allez aller à
la rencontre des autres bien vous allez
aller aussi à la rencontre de
difficultés et qui dit difficulté dit
problème et dit fardeau or on reçoit
tous et toutes un sac à la naissance
dans lequel on va déposer tantôt des
plumes des joies et tantôt des petits
cailloux les soucis
mais au fil des années ce sac va devenir
de plus en plus lourd si lourd qu'à un
moment on ne peut même plus y glisser
une petite plume autrement dit il n'est
plus possible de se réjouir de n'importe
quoi
et là ça devient très compliqué
d'avancer
première règle n'oubliez jamais que ce
qui se vit à l'intérieur se voit à
l'extérieur
tout ce que vous vivez à l'intérieur va
transpirer si vous souffrez à
l'intérieur ça va se voir si vous
souriez à l'intérieur ça va également se
voir il y a donc une solution pour ne
pas trimballer ce fardeau c'est de
déposer le plus souvent possible comment
en analysant le problème on se disant
que peut-être qu'on se fait du tracas et
que ce n'est pas utile mais il y a aussi
une manière de déposer qui est le pardon
j'étais quelqu'un de très en colère
évidemment j'avais un sac qui était très
très lourd et c'était si lourd à porter
que j'en voulais à la terre entière et
évidemment les deux premiers coupables
c'était forcément mon père et ma mère
mais je me rendais compte que finalement
ça ne réglait pas le problème de dire
que si j'étais malheureuse c'était de la
faute des autres
alors un jour je suis allée voir mon
père et je lui ai dit tu sais papa on a
complètement foiré le passé mais il
reste le présent et l'avenir on peut
peut-être faire quelque chose
j'ai envie qu'on puisse marcher ensemble
il m'a pris dans ses bras il m'a dit ma
fille je t'aime c'était la première fois
et
je pourrai jamais oublier
et ce pardon m'a permis de me libérer et
c'était tellement bon que je suis allée
voir ma mère et je lui ai aussi pardonné
de ne pas avoir été la mère que j'aurais
voulu qu'elle soit
libérez-vous de toutes vos rancœurs de
tous ces cailloux qui vous encombrent et
vous empêche d'avancer
enfin la dernière étape le R pour route
il est temps de prendre la route mais le
conseil que je vais vous donner c'est de
sortir le plus souvent de la route il y
a tant de choses à voir dans les
sentiers et c'est justement dans les
sentiers cabossés qu'on se sent vivant
soyez vous-même soyez unique ne faites
pas comme les autres lisez des livres
que vous n'avez jamais lu écoutez de la
musique que vous n'avez jamais entendu
allez rencontrer des gens que vous
n'auriez jamais cru rencontrer faites
des choses inédites soyez vous même et
surtout devenez unique pour rendre ce
monde formidable comme il doit l'être je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]